comme on peut
je veux pas vers le bas
à peu près là
après qu'on n'a pas bien fait c'est la
culture de l'échangé cultive
je vais parler d'entrée 5
en fait rentrer en italie aussi
les seniors
des grands troupeaux gestion
en regardant la libye la suisse peut
faire entre deux os soit les deux
villages paul douat suivront la tâche
peu peur
d'aubert le soir aux élus pour qu'ils
rentrent dedans leur ventre de beaucoup
maintenant 5
ces villages
bestioles faut qu'on avance
que nous
et sans pas provost la ville voisine de
souvent
pas de la peau au roi de 20 ans
je pense à bretelles
gbagbo
alors coup parce que
le tour
complètement stressée par les coop enfin
un truc
c'est d'ailleurs 230 qu'ils n'ont pas
poète et wallons balla bèye a pas de
gauche luan à bout
petite lucia ma voiture et compose des
sources à l'abord yade petit look je
suis là quand même sa magie à gauche je
suis le la riviera golf
cette baisse comme ça
mais en face de petits villages du
canton jean legault valoir
les ententois comptes bancaires et
derrière on en comptait pas vraiment le
cas de l'allemand ouais alors le klaxon
perdre deux tours n'ont pas perdre leur
note axa décroche quand des passagers
pendant près on voit pas souvent voilà
tu la vente de tricots pilule au plateau
des villes de salles de poker que ça
bloque ne dépasse pas
les tournées aux liens payants soit à
voile ces petits bateaux à voile le plan
toi que tu attends pas là voilà ce que
je dis c'est joli mais y associent
badauds les jolis jolis bateaux derrière
c'est très joli le le le paysage est
très jolie regarde c'est magnifique
c'est très bien ça est vrai que c'est
génial
tournée comme ça voilà regardant un peu
l'horizon père pense
plus faire un seul plan est arrivé ce
matin je prends tout cas le village
derrière que comme orange et elle porte
un joli plan b est aussi possible et
garder ce joli sans descendance est très
joli mais c'est le bateau empreintes du
borinage derrière le barebone pour les
tranquilles
autre jour arriva ok
rien du tout l'air d'un bain
le soleil est maintenant je l'aï va
arriver là remettre dedans la mâche pas
ses mots
attention
bolbec en contre jour là dessus que
envoyé en pension berre
cette hausse avait pas tous là
c'est pour ça que j'ai passé beaucoup
pendant
et en premier sur le bateau d'ici peu à
peu le voilier l'a déchue du canadien
croire histoire est bien gros quand j'ai
suggéré à ilebo c'est à tout regarder
les tu as super beau le regroupement de
succès pour foudre on est allé coupable
s'est dépeint pas quoi j'ai vu passer
les fruits quand les noirs baignoire que
derrière parlant à faire de ces cons
un beau blanc et noir de dans les jours
à venir
de plus en plus confiance tout en
avançant devant c'est pas pour toi eric
fava ou pas oui à temps je termine juste
un peu travaillé là bas tu verras c'est
joli c'est magique a raconté
je viens avec nous
les gens paient
dans le village de barinas jeu dans la
sueur ligne hier comme c'est beau de
vents forts qui impose un super pouvoir
au profit de son ami rhodanien
pas des oiseaux devant et tous espèrent
mme st
contre jour je vais te pousse
bah
le plus titré vous faire ensemble c'est
l'egypte qui va pouvoir y aller
doucement de terre était d'accord de
façon ponctuelle pour l'instant prévu a
fait 15 janvier des raisons tu as raison
tu as raison mais ça pour train on vient
sur le carré de la toile ce mail moi je
sortirai pay czar à voile du bateau en
groupe l'emploi pas si tu peux et
j'espère à eric c ideas que soit le dieu
l état palestinien je prends peur
de fait c'était le wild a vraiment
accompli en souffrent
seuls des sacs de riz ça fait 5 théorisé
la samp aux superbes super super super
super super super super bel écrin
ils étaient 800 voilà à la radio